[Music]
welcome back guys today we're looking at
everything you need to know about one of
the most complex and well developed
characters in attack on Titan Reiner and
we're also going to outline his unique
armored Titan abilities Reiner is a guy
who acted like a caring older brother to
Aaron Aaron looked up to him and wanted
to be like him until to his shock he
found out that Reiner was the armored
Titan who helped break down the walls
and indirectly murdered countless of
innocent people including Aaron's own
mother and today we're going to look at
why he did it why he betrayed humanity
and a survey Corps once again I want to
thank everyone for the insane support
we've been receiving on these attacks on
Titan videos I've been reading your
encouraging comments and I can honestly
say that you guys are best we are
actually going to be celebrating twenty
thousand subscribers and discussing the
attack on Titan to finale on Twitch this
Saturday at 8 p.m. Eastern Time so check
out our twitch in the description and
come hang out and play some party games
with us and if you happen to be new to
the channel be sure to subscribe because
we have many attack on Titan videos on
the channel and many more on the way as
always there will be among us spoilers
so proceed with extreme caution if
you're psyched and ready to go smash
that like button and let's do this
before we get into Ryder's backstory
let's cover some basic facts Reiner is
185 centimeters tall or 6 foot 1 he
weighs 95 kilograms or 210 pounds his
birthday is August 1st in his birthplace
Isla Vario internment zone he was born
to an LD and mother Karina and an
unnamed Marlena father his official rank
is vice commander and Hajime isayama
has said that he based his titans design
on Brock Lesnar interesting enough
alright now let's go back to the
beginning Reiner was born in the nation
of Marley which is a nation outside of
the walls which discriminates against
LDN people because among other reasons
they have the ability to turn into
Titans in are as a result viewed as
monsters rather than humans if you want
a more thorough explanation of Marley
and its history check out a mere and
jaws Titan explained where I go into it
in more detail in short the large
majority of people in the walls on the
island of
parodies rld ends but on the continent
Aldean people are forced to live in
designated areas and if they leave this
area without permission they have to pay
either through labour or physical
punishment that there's also a common
punishment for example Gregor's sister
was torn apart by dogs for leaving the
Libero internment zone Rainer was also
born in this internment zone to an LDN
mother Karina and Marlon father now this
is the only instance in the manga so far
where and LDN had a child with a marlane
we learned in chapter 94 of the manga
that this is considered to be very
disgraceful and as a result Ryder's
father's out of the picture and Reiner
cannot tell anyone the truth I can't
wait to find out more about Ryder's
father and his possible role in the
Marlon government he is taught to
respect them are laying government and
that it is responsibilities of good LD
aims to wipe out the evil Island
Weller's then people will finally stop
viewing them as monsters and
discriminating against them when he is
old enough
Reiner decides along with his mother to
enter a Marlon government program where
Aldean kids between the ages of five and
seven compete to become marlane warriors
that will inherit the seven Titan powers
that Marlay has in their control the
Marlon government acquired these powers
during the gray Titan war but they need
LD ins to use the powers because Marlins
cannot become Titans only LD and Ken
when they're injected with a Titan serum
Reiner wants to enter the program
because those who become warriors can
gain honorary marlane status for
themselves and their families he strives
to become an honorary marlane in the
hopes that his father will come back and
they can all live as a happy family
however we have yet to be introduced to
Ryder's father it doesn't look like he
was at the family dinner in Chapter 94
so it seems that despite becoming a male
in warrior and inheriting the power of
the armored Titan his wish has not come
true nevertheless his mother and the
rest of his family especially his little
cousin Gabby are very proud of him in
his service for the Malayan government
surprisingly rhinos a young kid is
nothing like the character we meet at
the beginning of the manga and anime in
comparison with the other recruits
namely Galliard
Marcel Annie and bertolt Reiner has the
most trouble in the warrior program he
unlike the others that I just mentioned
does not stand out in any seemingly
useful way his last chance is a written
test and it is his loyalty to the Marlon
government which is evident in this
written test that gets him to the next
step after a while Zeke tells them that
the operation to infiltrate the walls
and take the founding title will begin
soon and so six of the seven of them
will finally be chosen to inherit the
Titan powers now why is there only six
I've been wondering was the seventh male
and Titan the attack Titan that the owl
managed to steal and pass on to Grisha
or is there another power in control of
the more laying government that we have
yet to see I've heard people argue both
sides but let me know what you guys
think in the comments below
anyways Reiner gets excited by Zeke's
news thinking that he'll finally inherit
one of the powers and make his mom proud
a Galliard mocks him he points out how
Reiner is the weakest of them and that
he will not inherit any titan powers he
insults him for constantly sucking up to
their superiors and his constant bashing
of the LD ends on parodies Reiner freaks
out and tells him that the island
dwellers are evil and it's outraged at
Galliard would criticize such comments
he threatens to report gal yards lack of
loyalty and hatred for that evil Devils
on the island it is even possible that
Reiner got the power of the armored
Titan because he did report Galliera to
the government but we do not know why he
got the power over gal Yard for sure not
yet anyways nevertheless this scene
really illustrates how fully brainwashed
Reiner is at this point even when
Berthold mentions the meters cursed and
how he only had 13 years to live if you
did inherit the power Reiner doesn't
care he just wants to become a hero he
believes that if he can punish all the
Devils on parody's he will be able to
save the whole world along with the LDN
people and then he believes he will make
his parents the proudest of all he
thinks that his father would no longer
be ashamed of him and will finally come
back into his life
talk about fields guys talked about
fields fast forward and Reiner ends up
inheriting the armored Titan and
accompanying Bertolt an easy canned peak
two parodies on the way to the walls
Reiner is attacked by the mindless Titan
Muir and Marcel saves him by pushing him
out of the way Reiner is greatly
affected by his friends death and
continues nod flashbacks of that moment
Marcel was confident and reliable unlike
Reiner and as Galliard comments later
Reiner adopts Marcel's persona when he
is pretending to be a soldier within the
walls which explains the drastic change
in his behavior now we come to the
beginning of the manga the year is 845
Reiner and bertolt breached the walls in
their respective heightened forms it is
Reiner who smashes through the interior
gate and allows the Titans to invade
wall Maria
at some point while people are fleeing
from wall maria the two shift back into
humans passed themselves off as refugees
and infiltrate human territory they stay
in a refugee camp until they are old
enough to enlist in the military
two years after to destroy the walls
they enlist and become members of the
104th Training Corps when Aaron is
having trouble maintaining balance with
his faulty vertical maneuvering
equipment Marcos sends him to Reiner and
Berthold for advice it is clear that
people look up to Reiner and value his
opinion in the training corps in fact
Hajime isayama even said that among his
fellow 104th squad mates Reiner is the
most popular boy just don't tell me
Quezada the head instructor of the 104th
Training Corps Keith notes that Reiner
has exceptional mental and physical
fortitude ironically some time during
this point
Reiner developed something like split
personality disorder unable to deal with
the guilt of betraying his new friends
he begins to suppress his memories from
our lay and the truth behind his marlon
warrior identity he usually believes
that he is a soldier defending the walls
from Titans and sometimes bertolt has to
remind him that they are not Humanity
soldiers but warriors from our lay who
destroyed the walls the head instructor
also notes that Reiner has a great
ability to gain the confidence of his
comrades unlike an e/m bertolt who tend
to be quieter and more standoffish with
the others whiners new personality makes
him the perfect Marlon mould Reiner
eventually graduates second in the class
right after Mikasa he also seems to be
infatuated with hist
later when the members of the survey
Corps are on horseback and trying to
avoid being eaten by the female Titan
and other Titans our man Jean and
Reinert find themselves stranded without
enough horses to escape historia still
using the alias Krista
comes along with two extra horses and
saves them Reiner is mesmerised by
historians beauty and wishes she could
marry her later when Connie is back in
his home village and here's the Titan
that turns out to be his mother
welcoming him home Reiner tries to cover
it up later when Connie brings the Titan
up again at Lou's guard castle
Reiner chastises him again and Amir who
also knows about Marley and that humans
can become Titans mocks him which
finally puts an end to the conversation
Reiner later talks to Amir and private
and asks her to continue distracting
Connie so he does not worry and so that
he does not find out the truth it is at
this point that Amir reads the food can
that is likely written in Marlon and
Reiner grows suspicious of her knowing
well that there is no way that anyone
who grew up in the walls should be able
to read it then Titans attack would
guard castle and Reiner ends up risking
his life to save Connie he pushes him
out of the Titans way similarly to how
Marcel push Reiner out of the way
further reinforcing Gal yards previous
mention point that he is imitating
Marcel after the Battle of Loos guard
riders having a hard time dealing with
the stress and balancing his two
identities then to everyone's surprise
especially Berthold Reiner approaches
Aaron out of the blue and tells him that
he is the armor tightening that Berthold
is the Colossus Titan he says that if
Aaron just comes with them the walls
will be safe Aaron tries to play it off
as a joke but Reiner decides that it's
time to fight and take the power of the
attack Titan and possibly the coordinate
that rest inside Aaron although at the
beginning it looks like riders armored
Titan is going to defeat Aaron's attack
Titan it doesn't work out like that
Aaron uses tricks that a neat autumn he
wrestles with the armored Titan and
tries to use the Titans own strength
against him Aaron gets Reiner in a
stronghold and riders armor begins to
crack it looks like Aaron is going to
beat him when the armored Titan screens
with signals bertolt to rescue him by
jumping from the
all in this Titan form and causing a
massive explosion the confusion and
steam allows them to escape with both
Erin and Amir when they are resting on
tree branches in the titan forest Reiner
mentions how he hasn't been eating
drinking or sleeping much lately then he
starts talking about how he should get
promoted by the survey corps for working
so hard and keeping the wall intact he
goes on to say how the story I must like
him since she is always so nice Erin
gets extremely upset but amia realizes
what's going on and bertolt again has to
remind Reiner that he is not a soldier
but a Marlin warrior Reiner is
noticeably upset and traumatized by
Bertolt words Erin calls them both
murderers and Reiner says that he is
aware of that fact and he is visibly
upset about it but goes on to say that
the writer and bertolt that Erin you are
dead in contrast with bertolt Reiner
believes they can trust
Amir because they shared the goal of
protecting historia Reiner tells a mere
that there's no future in the walls by
which he probably means that Marlay will
make sure to eradicate the LDN island
dwellers once they have the founding
Titan power in their control his story
as a member of the royal family will be
very valuable for marlane so don't want
to keep her alive it seems like Ryan
your promises to protect her once she is
in morally
which is important because otherwise the
government majors use her to breathe
role blooded LD ins capable of
inheriting the founding titan power
eventually the survey corps catches up
to them and Reiner transforms into the
armored Titan and keeps running while
also trying to protect the bezel and
keep the other members from capturing
Erin Armand tells Ryan and Berthold that
annie is being tortured endlessly and
they are horrified and distracted by the
news Erwin then rescues Erin and as they
retreat Reiner begins to throw Titans at
Erin Condren speculates that he was
hoping that Aaron would get eaten and
they would have an easier time
kidnapping and transporting the next
piping shifter who inherits the two
powers this also suggests a Reiner and
Berthold could have done this sooner
just as they got marko eaten by a titan
when he heard too much he could have
escaped with a new type of shifter
without much problems but they didn't
perhaps because they did truly view air
and answer
friend and didn't want to kill him if it
could be avoided this is when Aaron's
founding Titan powers manifest when he
makes contact with the smiling Titan aka
Deena Fritz if you want to know
everything there is to know about the
smiling Titan check out my last video
the smiling Titan explained link in the
description anyways Eren eventually uses
the power to get the surrounding Titans
to attack rider and Berthold they
themselves sensed it when Aaron used the
coordinate power but they did not seem
to be affected by it beyond that since
they did not attack the smiling Titan
when Aaron wilded Reiner tries to
protect Berthold from the Titans while
fighting them off and it is likely they
both would have been overwhelmed had it
not been for a mere who turns into a
Titan and comes back to help them escape
the Horde of Titans in the aftermath of
the Titan attack Reiner is physically
exhausted and mentally shaken after
everything that's transpired recently he
actually tries to let the MIR escape
since she will probably die if she
follows them back tomorrow late this
scene among others illustrates just how
much Reiner has changed since he
enrolled in the warrior program before
his main goal was to bring glory to the
Marlon government and make his mother
and father proud but now he wants a
mirror to escape even though he knows
coming back empty-handed would be
shameful before he wanted to kill all
the evil island dwellers but as a
soldier he risked his life to save these
island dwellers Reiner told Berthold
before that he should tell Annie he
loves her when he gets the chance
because only another warrior can
understand what they've been through and
it's very true everything that happens
on the island is classified information
so Reiner won't be able to tell anyone
how he made friends within the walls
he'll have to reinforce the common
narrative that they're all evil and
deserves to die even though the island
dwellers are just as human as his family
at home sometime after historian is
proclaimed Queen and a mirror is eaten
by Galliard we get a scene of the beast
Titan looming over a badly beaten up
armored Titan the two along with
vegetables are back on the island and
parodies after having gone back to Marly
to deliver a mere vegetal tan Reiner
want to prioritize the rescue of Annie
their friend because they are horrified
at the thought
of her enduring endless torture an idea
that Armand wisely planted in their
heads because the Beast heightened
however knows that the priority has to
be the retrieval of Aaron and the
coordinate power it has been established
that runner looks up to and greatly
respect sleek as a superior as a mere
pointed out he looked at the Beast Titan
like an excited child when he saw him
from buscar castle and he even mentioned
that Levi's humanity strongest soldier
is no match for the strongest warrior
referring to Zeke this is why it is so
surprising that Reiner tries to
challenge him and risks being charged
for insubordination losing his power and
bringing shame and who knows what else
to his family it shows how much he cares
for his friends even though him and
Annie never seemed especially close it
is clear that he is very concerned for
her however he loses the battle and Zeke
ensures him that if he challenges him
again and loses he will be forced to
give up the armored Titan power how he
managed to win so easily is unclear but
perhaps he wrestled him like he did with
Aaron or just threw things at him the
Beast time seems like doing that a lot
during the return to shegaon sheena arc
the two sides are preparing for what
they hope will be the final
confrontation the survey corps on the
one side and the three time shifters eek
Reiner and Berthold on the other peak
also a male and warrior and Titan
shifters with them although she doesn't
really fight much her Titans name is
Cartman and she carries cargo on her
back walks on four feet and is extremely
quick she is on watch for the survey
Corps and she is the reason that the
three know that the survey Corps is
coming and have ample time to prepare
for their arrival
Reiner hides inside the walls which is
interesting I look forward to
discovering more about the walls because
if Reiner could find space to hide in
there
perhaps there are other interesting
things in there besides the hardened
Colossus Titans some of you in the
comments
have even speculated that the ninth
Titan is inside the walls somewhere
which would be crazy
however writers great hiding places
figured out sooner than expected because
of Arman's quick thinking despite
practically getting his whole head cut
off by Levi Reiner miraculously survives
and shifts into this Titan form so it
seems like your body does not have to be
fully healed for you
shift into tighten form as Reiner was
suggesting to Aaron back in the Titan
forest once more Reiner and Aaron
face-off while they're fighting the
survey corps makes use of their new
thunder spears first blinding riders
Titan and then hitting him several times
in the neck causing a huge explosion
Reiner seemingly lifeless body is left
fully exposed in the top of his head has
been completely blown off however he
survives for reasons we'll discuss later
when we get to the Titan of specific
abilities using his Titan reiner gives
the signal that the beast Titan has been
waiting for
he throws a barrel with been felt inside
menthol doesn't follow the plan to
explode immediately because he sees that
Rider is exposed so he warns Reiner to
get on his back and eventually uses his
ability to explode and Ryan whose armor
protects him is one of the few people
who are unaffected by the explosion
eventually riders had regenerate he
doesn't remember what just happened but
he goes to help the Colossus Titan
anyways knowing that no matter what they
should be good if they capture Aaron
however again the survey corps led by
Mikasa used thunder Spears against the
armored Titan this time they used them
to unhinge his jaw and blow him out of
the nape of his Titan after he has been
defeated hanji finds a metal case on him
that turns out to be a Mears letter to
historian that he promised to deliver
lino refuses to answer any other
questions the hanji has and is about to
be executed but Jean convinces hanji to
check to see if they can steal the Titan
power from him by using the Titan serum
in Levi's possession in the meantime
however Zeke and peak come along and
snatch Reiner rescuing him in the nick
of time
then the group makes her way back to
marlane without Berthold fast forward
four years and Reiner is getting ready
to participate in the Battle of Port
Slava along with Zeke peak and Galliard
they are battling against the mideast
allied forces who had anti-titan
artillery at the climax of the battle
the Beast Titan is almost hit but Reiner
jumps in the way and saves him
nevertheless he is severely injured
proving that this new technology can
even penetrate more lays great armored
Titan although they win the war
the world sees as
through various newspaper headlines that
the male government's absolute control
over other nations through the use of
their Titan powers is no more
Reiner wakes up in a hospital where he
has been recovering from the damage he
has received from the battle Galliard is
there who starts scolding him and
talking about the memories he has
inherited from a mirror this is when he
calls Reiner out for adopting Marcel's
personality after his death it is clear
that gallier does resent Reiner because
he sees him as the cause of his brother
Marcel's death later he goes on a train
to labarie oh the internment zone and
their hometown with his fellow warriors
and warrior cadets Rainer talks to Falco
Grice a warrior cadet liners younger
cousin Gabby who looks up to Ryder very
much wants to inherit the armored Titan
from Reiner but Rocco doesn't want that
Falco asks Reiner if it's ok with him if
Gabby inherits the power and only lives
to be 27 because of Amir's curse or dies
even sooner because of an artillery
strike Reiner responds gravely that
inheriting the armored Titan is an honor
and that you should never speak ill of
it
Reiner threatens to report him to the
unit like he did with Galliard
Reiner says that because of what he just
said Sacco and his family will have to
join the ranks of the Titan weaponry ie
be turned to mindless Titans and
unleashed on an enemy nation so in this
exchange we see clearly what awaits
warriors who so much as talk ill of the
Titan powers not only is there
brainwashing at work from when they are
very young their family members are
practically the Marlon government's
hostages however this time it seems like
Reiner is trying to protect Falco
because he warns him that anyone who
overhears him talking like that would
report him and then he finally says to
Falco that he has to rescue Gabby by
surpassing her and inheriting the Titan
instead of her thus here we have Reiner
the model Marlon warrior who excelled in
nothing but loyalty also talking ill of
the Titan power it's clear here that
Reiner has grown and developed a lot
since he was a kid his loyalty is
brought into question again later when
he is eating dinner with his family he
talks about classified information he
mentions that the LD ends on parodies
were cool and barbarous but really he
mentions examples that actually
humanized the other survey core members
he even mentioned Sasha in the infamous
potato eating scene if you want to know
more about their conversation and
Ryanair's childhood I break it down in
my chapter 94 review which I'll link in
the description but the point is that
the family is shocked that he didn't
depict every island dweller as an evil
devil we can clearly see that Reiner is
no longer deny Eve kid he once was he
has been through a lot just like Aaron
in fact some of you in the comments
found it even easier to empathize with
Reiner especially after the last chapter
than you did with our brash in-your-face
protagonist Aaron I think Hajime isayama
does a great job of showing that there
is no good or bad characters here there
is no black or white here we are
swimming in a sea of grey and I think as
readers we're not supposed to know what
the right answer is at least not at this
point in the manga Hajime isayama writes
seek your own justice until the very end
it seems like that is what most of our
characters are doing they're trying to
do what's right from their own
perspectives seeking their own justice
now we have seen cracks in the armor
Titans loyalty to male so we need to
keep an eye on Reiner and watch what
he's going to do next
will he stick with them are laying
government for his family's sake or
begin to plot against the Marlon
government who has done so many horrible
things to the LDN people anyways that's
Ryan's character explained I told you
guys he's complex and well-developed
which is why this turned out to be my
longest video so far and we're not even
done yet
now let's look at the 15 meter tall
armored Titans unique abilities like all
Titans the armored Titan can
automatically regenerate wounds while in
Titan or human form however here's where
things get interesting
Reiner has also been shown to possess
the ability of regeneration with the
drawl which is the conscious control of
the regeneration ability Reiner can
prevent wounds from healing rapidly and
emitting steam so as not to blow his
cover as a Titan spy he is the only one
so far who we've seen using the ability
or is he well there is currently a
theory going around in the community
that the strange man in
the last two chapters of the attack on
Titan manga who has an LD an armband on
the wrong arm is actually Aaron and he
has infiltrated Marlay the theory is
that over the last four years he has
also learned to use regeneration
withdrawal and is currently using it to
pass off as an injured soldier in Marlay
so we will see what happens but I
definitely think this man will come into
play soon whoever he is the armored
Titan also has enhanced strength Reiner
smashed through the inner gate of wall
Maria with the help of a running start
the hardened skin on his fist also makes
his punch as much deadlier than that of
normal Titans these punches were
powerful enough to blow half of the
attack Titans head off probably the most
important and unique trait that the
armored Titan has is armor hardening
whiners Titan body automatically
produces hardened armor like skin that
covers most of his body except for areas
that are important for movement like the
joints on the back of his legs
Reiner can shed additional armor for
additional speed the armor is hard
enough to withstand concentrated cannon
fire without even stopping him along
with blows from unhardened Titan fists
and the blaze of the survey Corps
although what is very interesting is
that the armored Titan can withstand a
direct collision an explosion from the
Colossus Titan while the same collision
was enough to defeat Aaron's attack
Titan finally rider can also harden his
fingertips and use them to climb the
walls in my every Titan explained video
people also mentioned that the armored
Titan can breathe fire referring to the
moment after he destroys the inner gate
of wall Maria it might be more accurate
to call it a necessary release of excess
steam it should be noted that he has
never actually used this ability as a
weapon finally Reiner has used the brain
function transfer ability during the
return of their chigan china hark during
the fight his brain as mentioned is
destroyed by a thunder spear yet he is
still alive and able to control his
Titan he did this by transferring his
consciousness across his body's nervous
system in this way he could use his
nervous system with the Titans brain in
order to retain his memories
but as pencilled mentions it's very
dangerous and should be considered a
last resort when riders head regenerates
he cannot
member anything that happened since he
parted ways with better tones which is a
side effect from using disability and
there you have it guys wow that was a
long video if you made it to the end
type in thunder spear in the comments to
show that you made it this far thanks so
much for watching all the way through
you guys are amazing let me know what
you think of Reiner do you think he's a
traitor who deserves to be punished or
do you understand where he's coming from
let me know if you enjoyed this video
don't forget to smash that like button
and subscribe for more
attack on Titan videos until next time
see us space cowboys
[Music]
you